bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
bientôt il faudra faire une minute de
silence en commençant cette émission car
on parlera de quelque chose de défunts
l'économie
bonjour aujourd'hui on vous parle des
élections américaines du bilan de
monsieur trump un bonjour estelle
bonjour olivier bonjour à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouvel épisode de ses caches à
quelques semaines de la présidentielle
américaine
on va s'intéresser au programme
économique des deux candidats d'abord
quel bilan économique
pour donald donald trump qui de bayonne
ou de trump a le programme le plus à
même de redresser le pays qui prévoit
quoi se sont à lequel les questions à
l'ordre du jour de cette émission et
pour en parler nous serons en deuxième
partie avec à christian de boissieu
professeur d'économie à la sorbonne
joe biden donald trump les états unis
vont devoir choisir leur nouveau
président le 3 novembre prochain
vont-ils offrira donald trump un second
mandat ou vont-ils faire basculer leur
pays vers une présidence démocrate avec
joe biden on va s'intéresser ici au
programme économique des deux candidats
points communs et différences voyez cela
avec le tiroir cash d'antoine d'assas
troll contre buy donne deux candidats de
vision économique différente mais pas
forcément si éloignées autant jouer au
jeu des 7 différences
tous deux se montrent assez sceptiques
sur le libre échange et préfère
privilégier le made in america
quitte à taxer les produits de
l'étranger comme ça a été mise en place
durant ce dernier mandat
l'emploi est la priorité des deux
candidats normal avec une épidémie qui
en a détruit des millions trump affirme
qu'il ramènera la production dans le
pays pour ainsi rapatrier un million
d'emplois de chine tout en créant aussi
10 millions d'emplois en thibault a
seulement comment on sait pas trop en
fait pas vraiment de précisions sur la
méthode chez byden on a l'ambition d'un
salaire minimum plus que doublé à 15 $
de l'heure contre 16,25 dollars
actuellement
le candidat démocrate envisage également
un nouveau plan de relance à 700
milliards dont 400 pour acheter des
produits américains
on en revient au made in america et 300
pour faire progresser la recherche et
développement
finalement la plus grosse différence
entre les deux candidats tient dans leur
vision fiscale
trump veut continuer de baisser les
impôts comme il l'a fait lors de son
premier mandat
quand weiden veut les augmenter c'est
que démocrates étaient ni l'eau taux
d'imposition des gros revenus passerait
de 37% à 39 26 % quand pour les
entreprises
ce serait de 21 à 28 % on viens de
l'entendre c'est finalement sur la
fiscalité que se trouve la principale
différence entre les programmes des deux
zones et des deux hommes c'est karl on a
ce qu'il faut en retenir c'est ce qu'il
faut retenir femmes siècle le sur le
billet américain il ya marqué in god we
trust
on sait pas quel est le dieu dont il
parle moi pour moi c'est plutôt l'argent
et et je pense que c'est réellement ça
qui va jouer sur la sur la campagne
quand vous dites à un américain qui va
être taxés plus ils voient rouge et donc
comme ça seul son seul but dans la vie
c'est d'amasser des billets et bien je
pense que il ya de grandes chances que
là-dessus ce joue les élections et qui
ils pencheront plus tôt pour ceux qui
leur chante une jolie chanson comme quoi
les impôts n'augmenteront pas ce qui est
d'ailleurs en plus une quelque chose qui
est faux puisqu'on sait très bien que
toute la dette qui sont en train de
fabriquer ces des impôts c'est des
impôts des cas laisser des impôts qui va
leur tomber dessus d'une manière ou
d'une autre mais qui va leur retomber
dessus dans les années à venir donc que
la main en disant qu' il n'est
augmentera pas parce que en vue de la
présidentielle
l'autre dit qu'il va les augmenter mais
les deux les augmenteront simplement il
faut savoir si les américains seront
crédules ou pas pourtant les on l'a
violé les contours du programme de
donald trump sont quand même assez floue
on pour autant c'est vraiment sur la
fiscalité couture sg pour vous oui parce
que parce que mais comme tous les hommes
politiques ils vous il vous annonce des
programmes qu'ils ne tiendront pas et
est donc voilà enfin vous avez quelqu'un
qui aujourd'hui est capable de promettre
n'importe quoi du moment que il est élu
et l'autre en face fait exactement la
même chose ailleurs en premier temps
n'importe quoi en attendant d'être élu
donc je veux dire on est dans une
campagne qui déjà est à un niveau
de profondeur abyssale la carte des cas
il n'y avait qu'à regarder le débat
entre baden et rome sa volée pas bien
haut
et voilà et donc on a deux candidats qui
s'affrontent en racontant des sornettes
et puis une fois que les ils seront élus
vous verrez que le discours changera
mais mais le point de le point je vous
dis qui à mon avis est réellement le
point qui va décider des élections c'est
c'est comme toujours aux etats-unis
c'est l'argent donc celui qui en promet
le plus même si tout le monde n'est pas
dupe de ce qui va se passer et bien si
la majorité du ppt
ça marche merci olivier on passe tout de
suite à la deuxième partie de cette
émission
et pour parler de la présidentielle
américaine sommes en liaison avec
christian de boissieu professeur
d'économie à la sorbonne bonjour
monsieur de boissieu bienvenue dans ces
caches où les remous alors monsieur de
boissieu le mandat de donald trump a été
en traversée par la crise sanitaire du
côté de 19 avec une entrée en récession
à des états unis 8 4% à c'est le taux de
chômage évalué en août dernier avec un
pib qui devrait a plongé de 4,3 pour
cent selon les dernières prévisions du
fmi
au delà de la crise alliés aux convives
19 quel bilan économique est ce que vous
retenez vous du mandat de donald trump
d'abord je voudrais dire que je suis en
grande partie d'accord escaliers olivier
tout à l'heure sur le rôle de la
fiscalité alors vous m'interrogez sur le
un peu le rétroviseur c'est à dire
qu'est ce quelle leçon tirer ces quatre
hommes politiques économiques
bon il a eu beaucoup de succès au
démarrage avec il est clair que la
baisse des impôts
apportez des foules il a certainement
dopé l'économie américaine vous pouvoir
en février février 2020 c'est à dire à
la veille du confinement
le taux de chômage est tombé à 3 5%
c'est un taux de chômage de plein emploi
et ça faisait longtemps que les états
unis avaient pas connu un taux de
chômage de 6 bat donc durer jusqu'à la
fin 2019 l'économie américaine soutient
soutient le président en place le départ
le débat des élections c'est quand même
l'année 2020 avec cette ce mélange de
crise sanitaire et de crise économique
les deux étant liés par rapport à ce qui
est des viviers je crois que la
fiscalité va être très important tous
les engagements fiscaux
même s'ils sont pas tenus en réalité
voix est important mais je pense quand
même que la situation du marché du
travail joue un rôle à dire que il ya
une très forte volatilité du taux de
chômage de l'année 2020 jeudi trois et
demi pour cent taux de chômage en
février 15 % en avril 15 % deux mois
après on est tombé à 8 et qu'elle vous
l'avez 18.4 et il y aura peut-être un
chiffre de chômage puis la tombe et
d'ici là
mais voilà donc il ya quand même 11
millions d'américains qui sont qui s'en
chargent d'emploi et il ya 25 millions
d'américains qui ont vu leurs revenus
baisser cette année on disait juste pour
revenir sur le bilan de donald trump
invoquant même en sur cette citation
nous prenions une direction jamais vu
l'économie la plus florissante les plus
bas chiffres du chômage de l'histoire du
pays
ce sont là les mots un de donald trump à
propos de la situation économique des
etats-unis avant l arrivée de la crise
du côté de 19 vous êtes d'accord avec ça
non je parle d'accord avec ça pour la
bonne et simple raison que si je voulais
10 x fois ici le chiffre du le chiffre
du chômage qu'un chiffre politique c'est
pas le chiffre réel et ça ne reflète
absolument pas la réalité du marché de
l'emploi aux etats unis marché de
l'emploi aux états unis où ça il ya il
faut bien comprendre comment ces
commencé calculer comment sont calculées
les
les créations d'emploi etc c'est parce
que c'est c'est vraiment intéressant
on parle beaucoup de de ces chiffres en
disant ah mais c'est merveilleux ils ont
créé un million d'emplois ils ont créés
etc
il faut savoir que alors qu' on pourrait
avoir des chiffres réels facilement
puisque je vous rappelle que le le les
impôts sont pris forfaitairement à
l'émission et donc vous avez le le fisc
américain qui a absolument toutes les
données et qui pourrait parfaitement
faire un état réel de la situation mais
en fait on ne fait pas ça on fait un
sondage un sondage dans le pays le plus
avancé du monde on fait un sondage pour
savoir combien il ya d'américains au
chômage ont fait un sondage donc avec
tous les défauts que peut avoir un
sondage est ensuite qu'est ce qu'on fait
eh bien on le corrige et on le corrige
avec un modèle mathématique qui ne
correspond à rien qu'ils avaient été
demandées mis en place par monsieur
reagan donc ça date et qui vous sort un
chiffre qui ne correspond à pas grand
chose qui est laid dans les créations
d'emploi corrigé par les créations
d'entreprises et quand on dit que en
moyenne les états unis craie
un certain nombre d'entreprises par mois
et que ces entreprises sont censés
embauché etc et donc on a un modèle
mathématique qui par exemple en 2008
2009 où il y avait croyez moi beaucoup
plus de destructions d'emplois que de
que de création eh bien on a eu sorti du
chapeau comme ça dans ces chiffres
huit cent mille personnes qui ont été
créés dont le poste a été créé alors que
ça ne correspondait absolument à rien et
900 mille l'année suivante
donc on est sur des chiffres qui sont
complètement manipulé complètement faux
et je peux vous dire une chose c'est que
le plein emploi
juste avant le coc vide c'était une
blague et en plus après on a eu pendant
toutes les années qui ont suivi 2008
on a eu des destructions d'emplois à
temps plein et des désengagements à
temps partiel avec des gens qui avaient
deux trois boulots qui étaient les
petits boulots et qui évidemment ne
donnait droit à rien ne donnait pas
droit au chômage etc tout ça ça a été
fait pendant les années entre 2009 et
2017 2018 et puis on en paye aujourd'hui
les pots cassés
je suis en désaccord total avec olivier
les états unis c'est pas la corée du
nord 1 c'est pas la chine
du point de vue la même manipulation des
statistiques faut quand même pas
exagérer
deuxièmement votre analyse des chiffres
de chômage est peut-être valable sur le
pont ces sorties de terre peut-être des
régions ils sont pas économie citons pas
statisticiens sûr qu'ils votent
jan bucquoy les chiffres de créations
d'emplois le taux de chômage officiel
qui soit valable ou pas valable c'est ce
que je vous dis c'est ainsi qu'en
politique donc et non et panda son
fromage
je suis désolé il ya des choses qu'on
peut dire il ya deux choses qu'on peut
pas dire je suis pourtant défend 13 voix
vous savez trump j'en ai rien à faire
sur le fond et fait plutôt moi je suis
plutôt sensible à candidatures byden
mais je dis simplement un décor unique
pâtit à n'importe quoi mais je ne dis
pas n'importe quoi est ce que ce que je
vous ai dit
sur le lago rythme qui avait été demandé
par reagan est une erreur non oui ou non
les jurés laissiez ou pas les jurys ton
foot de teint hâlé moi je vous dit pas
s'il s'en fout tout s'ils ne s'en
foutent pas je vous dis la réalité la
réalité des choses c'est ça alors
maintenant vous pouvez dire que c'est
faux ce que je dis mais il va falloir le
prouver parce que moi je peux le source
et si vous voulez voilà on peut pas
discuter de chiffres qui sont faux et
les communautés en disant mais c'est
génial non le chiffre il faut n'avons
pas tout chiffres je vous avais d'autres
chiffres sur le taux de chômage
américain est débout oui monsieur
christian de boissieu vous parlez des
chiffons d'ajustement sans jeter un oeil
à ces chiffres en 2016 la hausse du pib
des etats unis s'était abîmé à 1 25% 2 3
% en 2017 avant d'entendre 2,9 pour cent
en 2018 du côté de la création d'emplois
par mois en moyenne l'économie
américaine a créé à 180 3000 emplois en
2010 7 225 milles en 2018 contre 195
milles en 2016 et 226 milles en 2015
sous l'ère obama donc donald trump
concrètement est ce qu'il a réussi à
redresser l'économie américaine ou alors
est ce qu'il a hérité d'une situation
qui était déjà prospère avant
concrètement c'est à dire qu'il ya eu
dans les années à travers les années il
ya une mode états unis une baisse de la
croissance potentielle
ils sont plus régulièrement à 4% de la
séance les rôles moyen terme
vous avez donné de chiffres qui montrent
qu'ils sont plutôt autour de 2,2 et demi
quand il n'y a pas de crise la
croissance potentielle a baissé et
derrière la croissance effective à
baisser alors c'est tout le débat sur
l'évolution de la productivité
le fait que les nouvelles technologies
pour l'instant sont pas traduites par
des gains de productivité d'aspiration
des gains de productivité et le débat
sur ce qu'on appelle au fond le stade
national
est ce que est ce qu'on va dans le mur
du prévu la croissance aux états unis
heures ce débat il a été alimenté ces
quelques années parce que je viens de
dire sur le le ralentissement des gains
de productivité la baisse de la
croissance potentielle est effectif donc
là si vous prenez les années 2020 et
puisqu'il est prévu pour 2021 est la
lumière des chiffres du fonds monétaires
qui sont tombés il ya quelques jours
bon ils vont faire cette année une
récession 2020 qui est moins forte que
ce qui était prévu encore il ya quelques
mois ils vont faire une récession à peu
près de 2 - 4 - 4 3 % dit il a fini dans
l'enseigné projection donc une récession
moins forte
enfin qui est quand même important moins
forte que ce qu'on a en europe même si
c'est difficile de faire des
comparaisons à la fois dans l'espace et
dans le temps et puis l'année prochaine
en 2021 offert un rebond moins fort et
ce qui me fera t code quand on regarde
les prévisions à moyen terme de la
famille pour les états unis vers 2023
2022 2023
on a le sentiment que l'économie
américaine va revenir vers cette
croissance potentielle je répète kbc
depuis depuis des années qui autour de
domenech et je termine en disant que en
liaison avec la baisse de la croissance
potentiel de croissance et de cuivre sur
le moyen terme
vous avez un ralentissement de
ralentissement des créations d'emplois
voilà ce que je peux lire mais si on va
marquer pour te poses on va revenir dans
un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez on parle de l'élection
américaine et des programmes économiques
de joe biden et de donald trump avec
christian de boissieu professeur
d'économie à la sorbonne un mot à
messieurs sur le plan de relance proposé
à part joe biden c'est le fameux big bag
better que l'on pourrait traduire par
reconstruire mais en mieux un plan de
relance donc de 700 à 1000
de dollars 4,5 milliards seront
consacrés à l'achat de produits et de
matériaux dont le pays a besoin pour
moderniser ses infrastructures par
exemple et les 300 autres milliards
iront à la recherche et au développement
avec un volet sur les énergies
renouvelables par exemple olivier à
votre avis sur ce plan de relance de joe
biden c'est que dire un plan de relance
de 700 milliards sur un pib qui en fait
vingt mille et qui vient après une une
on va dire une inondation total de
billets sur les sur les états unis la
planche à billets tourne à plein pot et
on vous dit on va utiliser 400 milliards
pour refaire des infrastructures aux
états unis quoi dire rien dit rien c'est
pour moi c'est absolument inexistant et
puis ce qu'est ce que je vous dis c'est
quoi ça fait partie de toutes ses
promesses
que peuvent balancer des politiques en
sachant pertinemment que de toute façon
ils ne tiendront absolument rien de ces
provinces la passe qu'une fois qu'ils
seront arrivés au pouvoir ils
s'apercevront que c'est pas en
s'endettant un peu plus et on injecte en
un peu plus souvent sur des baies
soi-disant investissements mais keane
qui s'avère ne pas en être c'est à dire
ne jamais rapporter quoi que ce soit au
pays sauf ponctuellement fournir un peu
de boulot c'est pas c'est pas comme ça
qu'on relance un pays et surtout sur
quelque chose qui est fondamentalement
structurel depuis depuis des années
monsieur doit cieux parlé tout à l'heure
de la croissance potentielle
on a une croissance potentielle qui
diminue et ça dans tous les pays
occidentaux pour des raisons
démographiques pour des raisons de
moindre progrès technique parce que
figurez vous que quand votre iphone à
des coins carrés au lieu d'avoir des
points on s'est pas forcément quelque
chose qui apporte de la croissance donc
vous êtes sûrs d une pente qui est une
pente descendante avec un endettement
qui croît de façon exponentielle lui et
qui pèsera sur la croissance d'une façon
ou d'une autre derrière donc on est en
train tous et je voulais dit plusieurs
fois ici on est en train tous deux se
japonisé gentiment avec avec des
problèmes qu'ils sont jamais adressé est
ce que vous avez entendu une fois un
américain parlait de de la démographie
jamais dans les dirigeants est ce qu'on
en parle ici
jamais non plus donc vous avez
évidemment un problème de croissance et
qui ne date pas d'hier et qui décroît et
qui aujourd'hui arrive sur des
croissances qui sont potentiellement en
europe probablement entre 0 et 1% et et
aux etats-unis peut-être entre zéro et
un emmy donc franchement c'est pas
brillant et en tout cas ça ne sert ça ne
pourra pas réellement faire ni baisser
le chômage ni relancer les choses et en
plus payer les dégâts qu'on vient de
faire depuis des années cresson à des
voix si votre avis van baker
mais ce qui frappe c'est que d'abord ce
chiffre de 700 milliards de dollars
il est nettement inférieur aux débats
actuels d'un plan de relance qui a été
présenté devant le congrès américain qui
va prendre pas passé où les démocrates
majoritaires à la chambre des
représentants pour une relance à 2200
milliards de dollars et les républicains
après avoir été extrêmement réticent
était prêt à aller jusqu'à 1700 1800
donc on est dans un ordre de grandeur
qui était pas le même qui est sans doute
au fond le retour
une sorte de principe de réalité par par
le candidat byden le deuxième point et
voyez tu fais pas tu cherches pas est en
désaccord système systématique avez-vous
olivier bon on est dans un contexte où
d'open bar d'open bar partout open bar
il faut peut-être parler de la fed quand
même un moment donné on l'a dit enfin
vous l'avez pas cité mais vous avez le
pied le thème la banque centrale
américaine comme la bce comme toutes les
autres banques centrales lâche tout elle
est à la chtouille donc sous cet angle
là il n'y a pas de singularité des états
unis par rapport à l'europe ou par
rapport aux autres régions du monde dont
il n'y a pas de singularité le la dette
publique américaine va atteindre 100% du
pib le déficit chargée stéphane séguin
le déficit budgétaire américain il va
être au tour je sais pas entre 10 et 15
% de leur pib
on va attendre la fin de l'exercice mais
ça va être à peu près de cet ordre là
c'est à dire pas très loin de ce qu'on a
dans certains pays européens
bon donc on est en train de raser gratis
je dirais là où je suis moins sévères
sur ce mot fait que olivier c'est que
moi je pense que ce que font à la fois
les banques centrales et les états
aujourd'hui ce qu'il avait commencé de
faire après la crise de 2007 2008
ces deux d'éviter une déflation mondiale
bon donc c'est mon interprétation alors
l'inflation reste trop bas
l'inflation reste trop basses dans la
zone euro aujourd'hui on est près de 0%
en rythme annuel et même aux états unis
même s'ils sont un peu plus haut que
nous l'inflation reste pro base par
rapport aux objectifs des banques
centrales
c'est la raison pour laquelle affaires
fédérales d'ailleurs comme la bce est en
train de mettre en oeuvre une sorte de
révision de sa stratégie monétaire parce
que parce que l'objectif d'inflation les
patins pour des tas de raisons sur le
thème je reviens pas là où je rejoins
olivier c'est que ouais je dis à court
terme je pense ya pas tellement d'autres
solutions que de la chaîne alors il y
aura une aura une facture au bout du
compte une facture à régler et c'est des
problèmes de dette dans un contexte
pour le mans s'est pas l'inflation qui
va alléger le poids réel des dettes
puisque l'inflation à mon avis va rester
basse aux états unis comme ailleurs
ailleurs ça veut dire les pays avancés
là que j'ai en tête dans les deux ou
trois ans qui viennent
est ce qu'il y aura à terme une
augmentation des impôts tout cas y aura
your eyes à ce conflit de générations
qui paraît exister aux états unis comme
pour nos nobles comme partout entre les
jeunes et les moins jeunes et ce conflit
de générations et accentuer donc
seulement par l'augmentation des dettes
publiques par l'augmentation du chômage
des jeunes est accentuée par la nature
même de la crise du corona qui fait que
au fond les anciens ont le sentiment
d'être contaminés ou la réalité je sais
pas si c'est le sentiment que la réalité
d'être contaminé par les plus jeunes
donc à la fois du point de vue
économique 2.2 finances publiques et du
point de vue sanitaire
vous l'avez compris génération je
termine un mot sur l'aspect politique
industrielle un mot sur l'aspect
politique industrielle noah je ne
constate que partout il ya il ya un
retour des politiques industrie alors
byden il sera sans doute probablement
aussi protectionniste est aussi agressif
sur le plan mondial que trump durera pas
tellement différent sur la scène
mondiale faut pas d'humour européen
penser que l'arrivée de ban possible de
byden va régler les problèmes de la
gouvernance mondiale
c'est faux y aura pas de différence même
avec la chine je peux en faire la même
chose sauf que là d'une chose
merci beaucoup monsieur de boissieu on
est malheureusement obligés à de
refermer ce chapitre le temps a en
partie été coulé mais on ne manquera pas
de reparler de l'élection américaine
dans les prochaines émissions merci
beaucoup christian de boissieu d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur d'économie à la
sorbonne olivier on passe tout petit aux
questions cash
merci
et comme chaque semaine dans les
questions cash olivieri pour vos
questions que vous lui adressez sur les
réseaux sociaux ou en commentaire des
vidéos voici cette semaine les questions
sélectionnées
olivier faut-il retirer toutes les
pannes pour la placer dans des valeurs
refuge comme l'or oui je vais filtre
l'opéra tirez vous oui pas que l'ordre
dans tout ce qui est actif réel
c'est-à-dire or argent platine ce que
vous voulez c'est mieux en tout cas que
de laisser son argent dans une banque où
il est en risque ou dans une
assurance-vie où il est en risque
on vous répondait aussi à la deuxième
question à celle de virginie où faut-il
placer son argent aujourd'hui
et bien alors après c'est tout va
dépendre de ce que de ce que vous avez
comme argent c'est à dire que si vous
avez sur un compte quelques milliers
d'euros
et bien malheureusement vous n'aurez pas
d'autre choix que de les retirer de les
mettre sur sur un autre support sur un
actif réel et comme ça on pourra ça sera
beaucoup plus difficile de venir vous le
cherchez et devenir vous le le faire
fondre en revanche pour ceux qui ont
beaucoup plus d'argent à ce moment là
vous avez d'autres techniques c'est à
dire que vous pouvez aller dans des
banques privées qui donc ne seront pas
impactés comme les banques généralistes
vous pouvez à ce moment-là investir dans
des boîtes mais investir pas dans des
boîtes qui sont cotées dans des sociétés
qui ont un bon business model qui qui
ont qui ont quelque chose à vendre
d'intelligent et dans lequel vous pouvez
soit leur prêter de l'argent soit
investir mais qui sont ne sont pas
cotées en bourse et donc ne seront pas
emporté par le tsunami qui nous attend
merci beaucoup à olivier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain rendez vous la semaine
prochaine en attendant pour voir ou
revoir nos précédents numéros rendez
vous sur notre site internet à l'adresse
rt france point tv olivier on se quitte
avec votre dernier mot mais où est le
fond de cette campagne américaine
j'ai l'impression qu'il continue de
creuser